kevin stefanski brown's head coach on
the news that otto beckham jr has a torn
acl will miss the rest of the season
strange situation for cleveland because
look we talked about this a little bit
yesterday
given the possibility he was going to be
out for an extended period of time
i really don't know how much
worse it makes the browns frankly right
we saw what they did
on sunday without him on the field we'll
find out
we'll find out and i think what happens
over the course of the next nine weeks
will will allow the browns to make a
decision about the future with otto
beckham jr they're going to come out of
this season
saying we need this guy no matter what
or we're at the point where we can move
on
from him i don't think there's going to
be a middle ground or let's give it
another season let's see what happens
now
he's got an injury guarantee that kicked
in so you know
if if he's not healthy by next year
she's not able to pass a physical
then they're going to have to pay them
they're going to have to keep them on
the team but
i i i think that from a you know a trade
standpoint and that's
that's noise that that emerges from time
to time with beckham it happened back in
march there was talk of him being
possibly traded to the vikings
chris you and i both believe that maybe
he could be or should be or wanted to be
traded by the browns
that's all done for now but i think that
what the browns do without him is going
to be the ultimate litmus test on
whether or not they want him for next
year and
i i i i know he's still one of the most
skilled receivers in football but when i
look at this brown's offense right
i really don't think they're going to be
worse without him
because it lets them play the game they
need to play the game run the ball and
throw the football to the open man
without this constant nagging sense of
we've got to get the ball to obj well
yeah i think there is part of that i
mean baker mayfield certainly i mean he
seemed like he had finally got over some
of the hurdles about connecting with
odell beckham jr here this year at least
the last few weeks
to where finally there was a little bit
of a comfort level between both of them
you know i think the big thing too mike
and and to what you're saying is
you know it's not necessarily an offense
that lends itself to lots of
great receiver numbers and things like
that either so i don't know if it
necessarily always takes advantage
of all the things odell beckham jr would
have to offer
an offense really in a lot of ways as he
could as compared to maybe being another
you know a little bit more past oriented
creative pass scheme type offenses where
yeah odell special because he can just
flat out beat you deep
he can jump ball and randy macia and 50
50 catch it
and then he can run all like the julian
edelman underneath routes
at the same level julian edelman could
in his career you know in his prime
that and and that's not the way
cleveland you know runs their offense no
it's not
so you know again i don't know mike
either cincinnati last week
is not a good defense as we know so i'm
not shocked they look good
baker was amazing we have to give him
his credit i don't i'm with you i don't
know if we're necessarily going to see
it on a week-to-week basis where i think
it's going to ultimately hurt them at
least this year with obj
is when oh it's the ravens again or it's
the steelers again or maybe we're in the
playoffs and that's where he's going to
come through and be able to make a play
where the offense or somebody is not
going to be able to
deliver he'll be able to do something
with his extraordinary physical ability
i think that's where they miss him
the meat and potatoes plays in offense i
don't know necessarily but but but chris
they've played two good teams this year
and they've been blown off the field
first you got to be close you got to be
in the game for obj to do something that
makes a difference in the fourth quarter
he was open many times last week in
pittsburgh too i mean
there was there's he has an effect but i
hear what you're saying you're right
it doesn't he doesn't dictate the
offense and their success he certainly
doesn't
i i understand it he had a great press
conference last week in what quite
possibly will be his last one ever with
the browns where he spoke in very
responsible terms about going home
sick in advance to the steelers game
because he didn't want to infect anyone
else in the event that he had
coveted 19 but he also talked about why
he's demonstrative why he wants to win
and he made the comment at one point
about beating good teams that's where
this bronze team is and he's been around
enough to know it
you win the games you're supposed to win
you lose the games you're supposed to
lose and they're losing those
games in blowout fashion 38-6 to the
ravens 38-7
to the steelers they've got three more
games like that left
titan's raven steelers again but you
know what
their other six games
they can win them all they should win
five of them the only one that falls
into that i'm not quite sure which way
it's going to go
is this week against the raiders other
than that and then they have their buy
after but other than that raiders game
there's five that they should win
that's that's ten and six if they win
the games they should
texans eagles jaguars giants
jets those five games should be won
by the browns now with the eagles you
know how they get better as the season
goes on and they won the other night but
it was just the giants so who the hell
knows who knows who knows
but they should win those five and if
they win this one against the raiders
going to the bye week six and two for a
team that's gonna feel like it's two and
six
that's what's so amazing about this
they're the afc's version of the bears
but they do have a decent offense yeah
but there's just this sense that even as
they pile up wins there's this gloom and
doom chris
why why why is that there well i think a
little bit is like to what you're saying
like they haven't other than the colts
game
they haven't beat a team with you know
any notoriety yet and i think that's you
know
we're still not sure about how good the
colts are either
so i think there's that aspect we've
seen the defense you know
it's not a super bowl or it has moments
of being very
average below average i mean we've seen
joe burrow tear it up twice
you know of course the uh the the
steelers had their way with them last
week so
i i think again there's things to be
excited about you certainly don't want
to take away from a team that's five and
two
but i i think they're in that same book
as the bears a little bit to where you
go yeah
but the schedule kind of fell right for
them in a lot of ways
oh cowboys the football team the bangles
twice
right i mean you know this yes they
should have won those games the only
game you look at that you go though that
was 50 50
was the colts game and good for them
they did it so you know
you're right the raiders are going to be
tough i listen i the way their defense
plays too
i'm not giving them a slam dunk versus
the texans or the eagles they're either
either way
so uh we'll see i'm not giving any i'm
not giving a slam dunk in any game right
they just find a way
to win the games they should win like
they did on sunday against the bengals
and you got to give
credit to a team that can do that there
are too many teams out there
that don't win games they should win i
mean
the cardinals should be 7-0 right now
because they blew
two games they should have won the
browns
have figured out how to win the games
they should but you're never going to
win a super bowl
you're never going to come close to one
if you can't beat teams
you shouldn't and i think that's why
you know these browns fans understand
and and they want you know they just
anytime you get a little you want more
anytime you get a little more you want
more and they want to be an
instant high level contender they don't
want it to be gradual
they want to go 0 to 120 like that and
you know that's not going to happen it's
going to be a process and part of the
process is figuring out where obj fits
alternate universe yes obj doesn't get
injured on sunday
does he get traded this week i'm gonna
say no
just because they're five and two and
kind of like got a good thing going
i think they probably would have field
some calls and
you know been interested but i'll say no
but i'm with you in the fact that
i don't expect him to be there next year
especially with the salary cap issues
looming and all those type of things
yeah i agree with you and then the
question is when will he be healthy
when will a trade happen because that's
the thing chris until you know he's
let's assume he's not let's assume let's
assume
sometime pre-draft so you can trade a
20-21 pick
that he's healthy and he's good to go
what's his value um that is a good
question i mean it's certainly gonna
he's gonna still
i think as long as he shows like hey
this was just a normal
acl tear right and he just it's just
that
i i don't think teams will be scared
away not from acls not in 2020 or 2021.
the ability to recover from that is is
pretty you know pretty amazing at this
point so
um first round and probably some change
but that gets hurt with the value of the
fact that yeah
it's not been great statistically the
last two years
and then yeah coming off the knee injury
so i you know i mean i i
probably should have been more prepared
for this but i'm going to say a
first-rounder and some sort of mid-round
pick to go with it
yeah i i i don't think it's a
first-rounder at this point you know
there was chatter back in march from
wfan that
the browns were talking to the vikings
about odell beckham jr for a second
round pick now
now there's no hard way it's hard to
reconcile that
with muhammad sunu there's no that's
what i'm yielding at two
there's no way emmanuel sanders yielding
a three right
uh but but i i i
he's still a game changer that way and
the thing that's going to help him too
much what's he done what's he done in
the last
three years that makes you think he's
still a game changer i don't know how
one time he took a slant pass and ran it
to the end well how about that reverse
when he had three
rockets up his ass and ran everybody up
uh by the dallas cowboys
wait you mean the one where five guys
were standing there watching him run by
oh i did none of them he ran by
you could talk about it all you want
yeah
nobody it's still a special play i don't
care what you say
and i don't don't see now again you're
gonna talk about the slants and things
like that and like
okay yeah i get it hey that baker
mayfield stunk last year
the offense stunk the year before that
he was with the giants and guess what
they stunk and eli manning so
what do people expect everybody's gotta
get over this one guy one thing
oh sorry okay you just gotta find
a team where they don't stink no one
quarterback's good
and they know how to use him yes and
they know how to handle him
and they know how to get the most out of
him right so where is that team does
that team exist in today's nfl i think
it may be the chiefs
i don't need him well yeah i mean you
know it just has to be an offense that's
expansive that way i think that's the
biggest thing you know
even in this prime with the giants you
know that they knew how to at least
use him and get him the ball where it
fell apart as eli got older and he was
just reluctant to hang in there and
throw the ball down the field to him
but i would think there's teams out
there that are going to be interested in
him because still the the
when you turn on the film and watch him
man to man versus anybody
he's pretty impossible to cover in a lot
of ways still he's still got special
skills
uh maybe not the way he did three four
years ago but he's still damn good
i think the fair trade without beckham
jr and this doesn't happen often enough
because i think teams don't want to tie
up
conditional draft picks i think what
needs to happen is
it's 20 22 picks and the final pick
depends on how he does what he does
what he does next i can see that the
more he does the more you give up
right that that's fair to everyone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports